two days ago Trump promised a major
announcement all caps many speculated
that he was going to announce his
running mate
perhaps he would announce a slate of big
endorsements perhaps he would announce a
coup d'etat
but instead
Trump announced that he would be selling
expensive computer cartoons of himself
hello everyone this is Donald Trump
hopefully your favorite President of all
time better than Lincoln better than
Washington with an important
announcement to make I'm doing my first
official Donald J Trump nft collection
right here and right now they're called
Trump digital trading cards these cards
feature some of the really incredible
artwork pertaining to my life and my
career it's been very exciting you can
collect your Trump digital cards just
like a baseball card or other
Collectibles here's one of the best
parts each card comes with an automatic
chance to win amazing prizes like dinner
with me I don't know if that's an
amazing prize but it's what we have or
golf with you and a group of your
friends at one of my beautiful golf
courses and they are beautiful I'm also
doing Zoom calls a one-on-one meeting
autographing memorabilia and so much
more we're doing a lot
the prize is dinner with me I don't know
if that's an amazing prize but it's what
we've got I love it I love it it's
obviously a troll it's obviously funny
it's Charming in fact self-effacing
humble even
but that's all it was it was just a big
joke
Trump has always been funny and he was
especially funny in 2016. but in 2016 he
was funny with a purpose he made jokes
about illegal aliens
to argue for closing the Border
they're rapists they're murderers some
are maybe good people okay but it was
too it's a joke but it's a joke that has
a lot of truth to it and it's a joke for
a political purpose he made jokes about
trade deals
for the purpose of defending the
American worker he made jokes about the
fake news
for the purpose of breaking the power of
the lying press yesterday Trump made a
joke about superheroes to
sell some expensive jpegs
we all want Trump to be funny but no one
wants Trump to be frivolous
he is entitled to raise as much money as
he can for whatever kind of pictures
that he wants obviously it's going to be
a very expensive campaign in 2024 but
this whole thing is going to fall flat
if no one knows what that campaign is
for 100 jpegs are not going to win the
2024 presidential race I know we're two
years out I know that there's not very
much that Donald Trump can do right now
he is not in political office
so his Rivals notably Ron DeSantis can
do lots of things
but
Donald Trump can't seem frivolous it's
good when he seems silly it's good when
he seems funny it's good when he seems
irreverent that actually helps
distinguish him from the rest of the
Republican candidates who just don't
have as much Razzle Dazzle celebrity As
Trump does Trump's one of the biggest
celebrities in the last 40 years
but it the jpegs are not going to win
the nomination okay I think right now of
Ron DeSantis within the same week
Donald Trump releases the 100 jpegs Ron
DeSantis and panels a grand jury to
investigate and prosecute the people who
pushed the covid lies and the covid
vaccines
as a republican voter I care much more
about the latter than I do about the
former I I don't know what Donald Trump
can do right now but he's got to seem a
little more focused
okay when I think about the 2016 race it
really wasn't all about him
he would put his name on things he would
he he would put his name on things like
he's put his name on things for 40 years
now big gold letters on top of buildings
but it seemed like that campaign was
about us that was that was his motto
remember Hillary Clinton had I'm with
her Trump said my motto is I'm with you
right he switched the subject of the
mutter and you really felt like this guy
is is doing this for us
he doesn't need to he's going to lose
money he's going to get a lot of agita
it's going to make his life worse in
many ways
but he's doing it for us
here I don't really see that what is
what is motivating the campaign is it
fixing trade is it fixing immigration
or is it telling jokes
I like jokes I like owning the lips but
I like doing it with a purpose
Trump used to have that energy of we're
going to panel the grand jury and we're
going to lock you up Dr fauci that
that's the subtext of impaneling the
grand jury the subtext is what Trump
said to Hillary in 2016 Hillary says I
wouldn't want to live in a country where
Donald Trump is President he says yeah
because you'd be in jail boom owned love
it yeah that'd be great
right now DeSantis is taking that energy
Trump trump is not the rest of the show
continues now I have got a great
written mailbag question from a retired
Jewish Christmas tree salesman I'm very
excited to answer I just see that name
right up there at the top so you'll have
to head over to the members block to
hear that question and answer it's also
fake headline Friday it's a fake
headline Friday is of course where Mr
Davies gives me five headlines and I
need your help to understand which one
is the fake
headline we will be doing that right now
please come over and help me if you're
not a member click the link in the
description and join us
[Music]
[Music]